ADAM LEONARD: My name is
Adam Leonard from the People
Development Departments.
And I'm so excited to welcome
one of my good friends, who
I've known for about
10 years now or so--
Diane Hamilton, who
is here with us today.
So Diane is an author.
She's a meditation teacher,
and a professional mediator
as well.
And I can't wait to
see what she shares.
So Diane, let me invite you up.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON:
Thanks, Adam.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks, everybody.
Sounds like my mic is on.
Yeah?
You can hear me OK?
Well, first of all, thank
you, Adam, for having me.
It's such a pleasure.
And I told him that I've
been on the Google campus
now for two days.
We did some training
work two days ago.
I facilitated a team
meeting all day yesterday.
And I've decided that
Google is the mecca.
People need to
come to Google just
to find out in what domain
you need to upgrade your life.
You can figure
out what foods you
should be eating, what physical
practices you should have,
what kinds of
technology is available.
It's so exciting and wondrous,
from one point of view.
I mean, it's really
kind of miraculous
how many movements and
culture, like different kinds
of movements have found
their home here and held
in what used to be considered
a corporate setting.
I think it would be
hard to call it that.
I'm not quite sure what the new
language is, but just the sense
that you're actually
really integrated and alive
and enjoying being
a human being.
So I wrote a book.
And my book was
published last December.
And I think there were going
to be some copies here.
They may still be arriving.
The book is called
"Everything is Workable."
And there's a really beautiful
publisher out of Boston
called Shambhala Publications.
Do any of you know
Shambhala Books?
Yeah.
So Shambhala is
interesting, because they
were one of the first
companies way back in, I think,
the early '60s or
'70s to really want
to bring the wisdom of
the East to the West.
And so they were
devoted to Zen texts.
They were devoted to
sort of Asian wisdom.
And there was also a book
that really made the company.
I don't know if you know of it.
The book was called "The
Art of War" by Sun Tzu.
So that book was translated
and published in English
first by Shambhala.
And basically, as
I understand it,
was the financial success
point for that company.
So I was really privileged
to be approached by Shambhala
and asked as a meditation
teacher, Zen practitioner,
and also a mediator, whether
I was interested in working
with them to bring
something into print.
So really, if you think
about the word "meditation,"
the word "meditation" has that
root, "med-" in it, I think,
which is probably Latin.
Does anybody know actually how
it translates from the Latin?
I don't know exactly.
But "meditate" and
"mediate" both literally
mean "to bring two into one."
So with meditation, when
you sit down on the cushion,
you're bringing your
body, speech, and mind
into one moment.
And you're creating
coherence with your life.
So you could say meditation
is a way of becoming one
with your life,
whereas mediation
is about bringing two
differing points of view
or two different sets of
interests or a conflict
in which there are many
parties into one solution.
So the impulse of
meditation and of mediation
are really the same impulse.
And so I gave a lot of thought
to both internal conflict
and also the conflict
that we experience,
both in our personal
lives and also culturally,
and you might even
say on a global scale,
and gave a lot of consideration
to how we work with conflict,
both within ourselves
and outside of ourselves.
And I wanted to make
the point that conflict,
while it is
uncomfortable, is actually
an incredible developmental
opportunity, that there
are things that can come
from conflict when you work
with it in an innovative way.
And because you are really
a culture of innovators,
that working with conflict
from a creative point of view
is-- there's an incredible
amount of growth,
possibility, and
new solutions that
can come from it when we
include it as potential.
The issue that we
have with conflict
is that the old
hardware, if you will--
I'm going to try to use
some of your language
and it's going to be kind of
pathetic, so just work with me.
So the old evolutionary
hardware does not
give you the
sensation in your body
that this is a creative
opportunity, right?
When the tri-brain-- we
have the reptilian brain,
the mammalian brain,
and the primate brain.
And when the reptilian brain
senses a threat-- which
whenever there's a
conflict, there's a threat.
There's a threat to our
resources, our identity,
our physical well-being,
the stability of our life.
Conflict is, by its nature,
threatening to the status quo.
So because it's
threatening, what happens
is that these chemical--
that the reptilian brain
stimulates the amygdala.
And the amygdala is
the signal function
behind the eyes that
stimulates the rest of the body
to fight or flight or freeze.
So you get this chemical dump
of cortisol, of adrenaline.
And so your later
brain can say, oh
great-- creative opportunity.
But your body is saying, I'm
getting out of here, right?
I'm going to fight, flight, or
disappear-- one or the other.
And so we have this problem.
We have this problem that
the sensation of conflict
does not support this notion
that it's an opportunity,
that it's a creative
possibility.
Because everything in our body
wants to get away from it.
The sensations of conflict,
no matter what you do,
do not feel good.
And so with enough practice,
you can override that sensation.
You can start to
wire, if you will,
the reptilian response to
these higher functions of mind.
And you can habituate
yourself to reinterpreting it.
And you can do a
counter-intuitive
starting to move towards it.
But there's so
much that you have
to kind of be able to
master in your own body
and also in your thoughts.
Because generally,
as soon as you
start to have the negative
sensations of adrenaline
and cortisol, usually
the cognitions follow.
In other words, your
thoughts are, like,
ooh, I don't want to be
here, why is this happening,
that person is wrong,
this should stop.
So generally, your
thoughts and your body
both wire to get you
out of the situation.
Does that make
sense to everybody,
what it is I'm saying?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Does the
reverse also hold
true, where your thoughts
can then [INAUDIBLE]?
DIANE MUSHO
HAMILTON: Absolutely.
And that's really what
we're working with,
is that what happens is you
enter into a feedback loop.
So when you work with
people with conflict,
one of the things that you have
to do is you have to-- well,
I'll give you an
example that's more
related to my own experience.
So there's a chapter in my book.
I was remarried, oh,
it's been now 15 years.
And I remarried a man
who had three daughters,
and their mother had died.
And I had one-- I have one son.
My son also has Down syndrome.
He's a genius.
And so we came together, and it
was incredibly intense for me,
because they hadn't had a female
in the household for five years
since their mother died.
They were all at different
ages-- 16, 13, 9.
It was really challenging
emotionally for me,
both to merge into the culture
but also to kind of create
certain kinds of
organization and patterning
that would work for
everyone, including me.
Mostly, that wasn't happening.
So I would just feel
overwhelmed, irritable.
I was losing my temper.
I just was starting,
really, to experience myself
in a way that was just
really not acceptable.
So I developed a
practice that when
I started to feel really
tense and really stressed,
and that amygdala hijack
started to happen,
that I would immediately
go upstairs to my room,
and I would sit down.
And the first thing I would
do is quiet my thinking mind
and just sit with the
intensity of the sensation.
Like where was I feeling this?
I could feel the increase
in my heart rate.
I would feel heat in my neck.
When we're in a conflict,
our primate history,
we tend to tighten the back
of our neck and our jaw
and hunch our shoulders.
And I could feel all
of that in my body.
My solar plexus felt
like they were on fire.
There could be a
sensation of nausea.
And the whole time, my thoughts
are saying, this isn't OK.
Why are these people
not listening to me?
What is the problem here?
They're all insane.
I'm living in a madhouse.
I don't like these people.
I don't want to be with them.
Now some tiny-- why
are you laughing?
[LAUGHTER]
Because you've been there.
You know this demented voice
that just takes over, right?
So my first thing
would be to just commit
to experiencing the sensation.
Stop the thoughts.
Experience the sensation.
Literally receive them.
Get to know them.
This is what this really
intelligent, evolutionary
hardware is telling me.
Like, what does it feel like?
It's really organizing
me to get the hell out
of here, basically.
So once I could pace that a
little bit, and the sensations
would start to calm down,
then I could pay attention
to my thoughts.
But even with the slightest kind
of attention-- it's amazing.
What I'm trying to
say is how quickly
the thoughts
reassert themselves.
So I would quiet my thoughts.
I'd be with the body.
And as soon as I'd turn my
attention back to my thoughts,
guess who was speaking again?
Yeah, the demented, insane
person would start speaking.
And so then I would just
pay attention to that,
and I would say, OK, what
is the wisdom in this?
What is actually right
about what I'm thinking?
Because we have a
tendency when we
get hijacked like that
to either be completely
under the spell of the
insanity or completely,
oh no, it's all fine.
Well, actually, no.
That's not the case.
How do you find this middle way
where you receive the wisdom?
So I would say, we
need more structure.
We need to create
some patterns when
we're having dinner together.
We need to actually listen
to one another and exchange.
So I really could
receive the wisdom
from what I was upset about.
And then when the thoughts are
now clarified, if you will,
you receive and
clarify the thoughts,
those thoughts
start to discipline
the physiological responses.
So then it's possible to go
back into the conversation.
And even if you start
to feel the contraction
or whatever those
are, you can sort of
breathe that out
and still assert
what is it that's important
around what I have to say
and this whole body of
conflict resolution skills.
So what I really want
to do is, in the book,
give you an
opportunity to consider
the evolution of
the body, consider
how to work with the benefits
of meditation practice.
And if you think
about meditation,
really, as an inner
technology-- that's
what it is, because you're
used to thinking in terms
of the innovations--
well, meditation
is one of the great ways that we
have of navigating our interior
and heightening the
discipline, if you will,
of how we perceive.
And then I wanted to also, for
the-- meditative communities
don't seem to have great
conflict resolution
skills, because they don't want
to feel "the conflict," she
whispered. (WHISPERS)
"The conflict."
There is no conflict, right?
So it all becomes kind of
passive-aggressive, right?
So bringing conflict out
directly for the meditators,
and for the mediators
to actually see
how much meditation really
supports the mediation
practice.
So those were the two
sets of technologies
that I was interested in
exchanging in the book.
But as I got into
writing it, I also
came to understand that there's
a third perspective that I
think is really, really helpful
when it comes to really giving
ourselves an
upgrade, if you will,
or what do you call it when
you go from 2.0 to 3.0?
Or where are you at now?
I don't know,
Google-- what is that
called when you go from
one level to another?
Is that an upgrade?
AUDIENCE: A release.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: A release?
OK.
All right.
Nice.
I like that.
So I realized that it was a
very incomplete discussion
if I didn't also
include something
about developmental theory,
meaning that there's
a whole body of
research out there
about how adult humans
grow and develop.
We all know that children do.
We all know that there are
certain developmental tasks
that get accomplished
at certain ages.
But the same is true of adults.
We also can expand and
grow our perspectives.
And the reason
that I got thinking
about developmental
theory is because I
was the director of dispute
resolution for the state
judiciary in Utah.
In other words, I
was responsible,
back in the '80s, for creating
mediation programs in the court
system.
And I was a very
naive and Pollyanna
and maybe "dumb" is just a good
word, in the sense that I sort
of was under the impression
that if I just set up
a nice environment, put some
tea and cookies on the table,
that people could
come into the room
and we could work
out the situation,
whether it was a
barking dog dispute
or whether it was a conflict
in a team, in an organization,
or whether it was a
transactional dispute
over land, a big land exchange
involving federal agencies.
I assumed with enough goodwill
and the right structures
and the right
conversation that we
could get the problem solved.
And guess what I discovered?
That it wasn't
really quite true.
And what seemed to be
at the heart of this
for me was that I
started to see that there
were limits to capacity.
And the capacity that
I started to notice
was the capacity to
take perspectives.
And it wasn't
necessarily pathology.
You know, I wasn't seeing
people who were sick and wrong
or people who would
have a DSM-III diagnosis
in the psychological world.
What I was seeing was
just a whole range
of people who had
different capacity
to take different
points of view.
So I worked with people who
came to me as a mediator who
literally could not take
their own perspective,
for whatever reason.
Maybe they were in an
abusive relationship
and it had been so long since
someone really asked them
what they thought.
I saw people who
were in a culture
where because they were young,
maybe their opinion didn't
matter, so they didn't
feel free to speak up.
There were just some
people who simply had not
been valued fully enough
to actually realize
that they had their
own point of view.
So I would work with
people all the time
under the assumption that
I was facilitating people
into agreement, but
there was one person
who was incredibly
disadvantaged because they
couldn't advocate
for themselves.
Does that makes sense?
So like I say, it started
to look developmental to me.
I didn't want to
pathologize these people.
It was a capacity that
wasn't quite online.
Does that make sense?
Then there was a
whole slew of people,
of course, who could
come into mediation,
they could take their
own perspective,
but whose couldn't they take?
Person on the other side.
Like even to try
it on for a moment.
There was no
bandwidth, if you will,
to hold another perspective.
Because as soon as we
have my perspective
and I'm considering
yours, what happens
in the body and the mind when
there are two perspectives?
What happens when
there are two-- maybe
engineers can help me.
If there are two
oppositional qualities, what?
AUDIENCE: Cognitive dissonance.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: There's
cognitive dissonance, right?
There's also an
energetic disequilibrium.
There's actually a pole in which
energy can run between the two
and disrupt or upset the system.
Now, I'm kind of
trying to present
that that's a good
thing, right, to be
able to feel that
cognitive dissonance
or feel that-- I don't know.
I want you to help me
because you're actually
trained in physics, and I'm not.
But whatever that is, if
you have two coexisting
truths in your head
at any one time,
you literally have to deal with
the disruption in your body.
So what do we tend to do?
We tend to push one
out right away, right?
Now, if you look at
your average news
channel on a daily basis,
how many points of view
are they able to hold?
They set it up as though they're
going to hold multiple ones.
And certain facilitator-type
newscasters will.
But lots of time what you get
is a collapse of perspectives.
And you get one sound bite
that just can be repeated again
and again and again,
because we find security,
because it's a single
truth, because it
doesn't create ambiguity.
And I saw lots
and lots of people
who were capable of that.
They could hold one truth,
but they couldn't hold two.
Right?
Then I started to
see these other kind
of qualities in people.
I would see people who
could have no point of view
for a long period
and be really quiet,
then I could see them really
very effectively advocate
for themselves.
And then I could see them
actually drop their position
and listen to what
someone else had to say,
and not simply listen
to it, but actually
identify with it for
a period of time.
And then I saw people who
could do even a greater trick.
They could take a third
person perspective.
So I, you, it-- they could think
about what a court would do.
They could think about what
a legal interpretation might
bring to it.
They could think about a
social impact on the problem.
And then, suddenly, there
was a much smaller group
of people who not
only could they
hold one, two, perhaps three,
they could hold four, five, six
perspectives at once.
They could take a
perspective on the process.
They could think about how
the process had evolved
from the past and where
it might go in the future.
They could think about what
the impact of the facilitator
was on the process.
And I started to
say, oh my gosh.
This is really important.
This perspective taking, and the
capacity to take perspectives,
changes the heart of negotiation
at such a fundamental level.
And we as mediators aren't
even taking it into account.
We don't even screen for the
number of perspectives somebody
can take.
Now I'm assuming
that in your teams,
that you're pretty good at
throwing the ball around.
Is that fair?
Uh-oh.
I'm projecting a lot of
idealism on your culture,
so just say yes.
Say, we're really good at it.
And then, even more complex,
once you open up the field
and can hold multiple
perspectives,
you can hear different cultural
views on the same problem,
you can see it from
many different angles,
the further task is how then
do you privilege a perspective?
What criteria do you
use to privilege?
And then I'd see these
people that very seamlessly
could privilege perspectives.
And so I started to think
in terms of development.
And shortly thereafter,
I was introduced
to an American philosopher and
writer and amazing thinker who
really has included a lot
of developmental theory
in his work.
And it really changed
my orientation
to how I do mediation.
Because I don't just assume
that everybody's capacity
is the same.
I assume that there are
differences in capacity
and that I have to
take that into account.
One of the really strange
sort of side effects
of this difference
is that you would
find people who were more
fluid with perspectives getting
the short end of the stick,
in terms of the deal.
Right?
Can you think about what
I'm saying for a minute?
Precisely because they could
hold more, they gave away more.
And I started to think
there are actually
ethical implications
to this issue.
It isn't simply that you're not
able to hold my point of view.
It's that when we
reach an outcome
and it involves money, that
you walk away with more
because you've been so
stubborn and you won't even
pick up my perspective
on this whole thing.
So I started to really feel like
there were lots of implications
to this that I really
needed to consider.
So if you're interested
in this book,
you'll find some chapters that
talk about this innate capacity
and also our ability to work
with complexity, which I know.
And the more complex
our situation
and the capacity for
working with complexity
from developmental
theory, you could say,
is one of the characteristics
of higher levels of development,
if you want to put it that way.
Now don't think about
higher levels of development
in terms of social
dominator hierarchies.
That's not the point.
It's more like the way in which
an atom becomes a molecule
and becomes more complex.
And then a molecule
becomes a cell,
and that becomes more complex.
So holding perspectives
is like that.
It's holonic.
It's not just simply
that you're somehow
better than the other person.
That's not the point.
OK?
So are you interested in maybe
just tasting a little bit
about how your perspectives
may have evolved?
I could take you through
a series of perspectives
that you could try on.
OK.
All right.
So let me just present it.
And for those of
you who are actually
watching the live stream,
if you have a piece of paper
and maybe a pencil,
and you might
want to write this down
and just explore this
while you're by yourselves.
But maybe you could circle up
with the person who's near you.
And I could just
invite you to try
on a perspective,
exchange with each other.
And then I'll say
"stop," and then we'll
go to the next level.
And you'll feel your
perspectives expand.
And then we'll get
a little bit bigger,
and then we'll get even bigger.
So we'll do four
rounds of perspectives.
Is that interesting to you?
Do you like the person
you're sitting next to?
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
I'm not going to try
to solve that problem.
I'm going to leave that to you.
Adam tells me you're
very capable here.
So let's think for a
moment about the boundary
around identity.
So we're going to
think about identity.
And we're going to
think of identity
for a moment as a
set of perspectives
so that who I am as Diane is
actually a set of perspectives.
It's a set of memories.
It's a relationship that
I have to this form.
It's a set of relationships,
some of which have persisted,
some of which have changed.
It's a set of values.
But those values
have also changed.
So all those perspectives,
from one point of view,
make up who I think I am.
So I'm going to
ask you to explore
the egocentric perspective.
But I don't want you to do
it from the point of view
that the ego is a bad thing.
Do you get what I'm saying?
Because lots of times, either
in our religious traditions
or-- we think of the
ego as somehow bad.
Why do we think
of the ego as bad?
Can anyone help me with this?
AUDIENCE: 'Cause
when it's in charge,
it kind of makes people shitty?
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON:
Yeah, people
get-- there's just
something quite
beautiful about what he said.
When the ego's in charge,
people are shitty.
That's the long and the short.
So the ego is not bad.
The ego is limited.
The ego is oriented
toward self-sustaining.
But there is such a
thing as a healthy ego.
There's a healthy sort
of ecosystem of self,
which is permeable, and which
can take inputs and give out
inputs.
And then the perspective
can shift to include more.
So an ego becomes bad
when an ego is exclusive.
Does everybody get that?
So that's the
thing I want to do.
A healthy ego is one that
has permeability and is
able to sort of drop
its reference points
and expand awareness.
But it isn't, by its
nature, bad and wrong.
It's only by its
nature bad and wrong
when it's exclusive and stops
taking in information or starts
thinking about others.
Is that fair?
Can we work with
that definition?
So all we're going to do is
just discover, for a moment, who
I think I am, or what
are the things I notice?
So I'm going to have
you complete a sentence
and just go around two or
three times in your group.
And all I want you to do is say,
as the egocentric self, what
I notice is-- OK?
So as the egocentric
self, what I notice
is I'm a visitor to
a culture and that I
feel incredibly excited.
And at the same
time, maybe I might
be even a little
apprehensive or afraid.
Just notice what
comes up when you
identify with the
egocentric self.
So if you're watching
the live stream,
just take a minute to jot it
down or think to yourself,
what do I notice?
And then we're going to watch
these perspectives grow.
Here we go.
I'll give you just,
like, two minutes.
Two and a half minutes.
Here we go.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
So did we get a
little sample of what
the perspectives are
like for the ego?
What are some of
the things that you
noticed as the egocentric self?
First of all, what are
you most concerned with?
AUDIENCE: Yourself.
AUDIENCE: Things in my day.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: Hello?
The self.
Things in my day.
What's on my calendar.
Good.
What else?
AUDIENCE: How do I fit
into this environment?
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: Yeah,
as the egocentric self,
how do I fit into this culture?
How do I fit into
this environment?
Who am I in the context
that I exist in?
That's a question
that's persistent.
Good.
What else did you notice?
And by the way, we're all
the same in this regard.
Even though we're
all different, we're
the same in that we're concerned
about similar kinds of things
from this point of view.
Please.
AUDIENCE: Physical sensations?
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: Totally
aware of my body, right?
I'm aware when I feel
comfortable or uncomfortable.
I can feel anxiety in the body.
I feel sensations of pleasure.
And I also have a
very strong sense
of where I end and
everything else begins.
You can have an
experience when someone
crosses your boundaries,
for instance.
And you just feel
that, like, ooh,
that didn't feel good to me.
Or somebody says something that
feels aggressive in a meeting.
You're like, oh, I
feel offended by that.
What else do you notice?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm watching,
or I'm paying attention
to what I'm getting
out of this talk,
and I'm evaluating
you as a presenter.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: Damn it.
Did you hear what he--
[LAUGHTER]
Right.
So wherever there's
an egocentric self,
there's a sense of the other,
so there's self and other.
So I am here.
I'm here to receive something.
I'm evaluating you
as the presenter
and whether or not
what you're doing
is actually valuable to me.
And that's an evaluation
that's happening all the time.
Great.
Good.
What other things do you notice?
Any egos feel stressed out?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: Yeah?
Say more, yeah.
How are you stressed out?
AUDIENCE: Next meeting.
Need to get ready.
Probably [INAUDIBLE].
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: Yeah.
Have to duck out a
little bit early?
OK, good.
So one of the conditions
that we want to pay attention
to whenever we're
identifying as the ego
is that there's a
sense of separation.
And because there's a sense
of separation, there's stress.
That is just the
fundamental situation,
is that we're always kind
of maintaining our image.
We're maintaining
our sense of safety.
We're maintaining our
sense of belonging.
So there's a constant
sense when I'm
identified that I have to
actually take care of that.
Now when you lose that
identification in a project,
or in a piece of music,
or you enter a flow state,
or you go to the gym, and you're
just basically washing yourself
in serotonin or dopamine, then
that sense of self dissolves,
and you don't feel
that stress anymore.
So there's almost
always, whenever
we're identified as
an ego, almost always
there's a situation of stress.
Does that make sense to you?
OK, cool.
All right.
So we're going to
grow our perspectives.
Are you ready?
So where do you think we
naturally grow, from the self
to the-- to our group.
Right?
To our group.
So what we're going
to do in this round
is I'm going to
ask you to identify
as the ethnocentric self.
Now this can be really tricky,
because if the ego feels
stressed, the ethnocentric
self feels safe in my group,
but your group can sometimes
feel threatening to me.
Do you get what
I'm talking about?
So what I'm going
to ask you to do
is identify with the
groups of your upbringing,
like where you grew up.
So as the ethnocentric
self, let's do it.
Let's the four of us just
model this for a moment.
So as the ethnocentric self, I
grew up in the desert of Utah,
and I spent a lot
of time in nature.
And I can say negative
things about my brothers,
but don't you.
Do you see that boundary around
the people that I grew up with?
So go ahead, Adam.
ADAM LEONARD: So I grew
up in Madison, Wisconsin,
and so identified more with
the Midwest in that sense.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: OK, good.
So what were some
values in the Midwest
as your ethnocentric self?
What did all your
people agree to?
ADAM LEONARD: Mhm.
Agreements?
There was kind of an
easy-goingness and niceness.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON:
We like to be nice.
If I'm from the
Midwest, we're nice.
OK, people?
You're mean-- we're not.
OK, good.
OK?
AUDIENCE: As the ethnocentric
self growing up in Canada,
I would say we were
nicer than you,
but we would never say that.
[LAUGHTER]
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON:
So as a Canadian,
we're nicer than Midwesterners,
and we wouldn't say it.
Hello.
All right, good.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I grew up
in Montreal, Canada,
in a French and
English community.
So there was a
very clear division
between the English, who
were also Protestant,
and the French,
who were Catholic.
So we passed each other on
opposite sides of the street
going to school,
going to church,
where we shopped for groceries.
Very divided.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: Great.
So notice your identity grow
and notice yourself belong.
Now some of you may not be
able to connect very well
to the place you came from.
But just do it for fun.
And then I'll help
you a little bit
with why it could
be useful to you
to integrate that part
of yourself a little bit.
OK.
So the sentence is, as the
ethnocentric self, here's
what I notice.
OK?
Two and a half minutes.
Go ahead.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Were you able to kind
of expand your identity
to include your group?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: Yeah?
Good.
And what did you notice about
expanding your identity?
What things came into
your mind, let's say,
that weren't there when you
were just identified as the ego?
What did you notice?
AUDIENCE: Had values.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON:
I have values.
Absolutely.
And the values were
the ones of the people,
my tribe, the people
I belonged with.
Very good.
What else did you notice?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: Yes.
We come from different countries
with opposite sensations--
I mean, opposite qualities.
And there were things that
we actually agreed about.
So in a way, what
you're already doing
is anticipating the
world-centric step.
Because my guess
is there are people
from all of your
hometowns who don't
move to a world-centric
level very easily.
Does that make sense?
Like, they're very
deeply embedded
in the ethos of
what you grew up in.
And the other is still
an other to them.
Right?
Does that make sense?
So whereas the ego,
there's self and other,
at the ethnocentric
level of development,
what is there, very strongly?
AUDIENCE: Us and them?
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON:
Us and them.
It's really strong.
So if you can cross that
barrier of us and them,
you're already
established at what
we would call a world-centric
level of development.
We'll explore that
in just a moment.
So what else about
ethnocentrism?
Did anybody feel some
sense of belonging?
Like, you felt
safe in your group?
Yeah.
Say something.
AUDIENCE: I was going to
say that very same thing.
[INAUDIBLE] us and them.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: Totally.
In fact, here's something
for you to try on.
I don't know if this
makes sense to you.
So guess what often
drives development?
Guess why we actually
grow in our identity,
or why we take on
more perspectives?
We call it the shadow.
Because I start to see that
this little point of view is,
what were some of the dark sides
that you were talking about?
AUDIENCE: Exclusionary type
of thinking and thinking
that you're special.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: Too much
prejudice, too much homophobia,
too much arrogance, too much
our way is the only way.
That starts to feel too tight.
Like, I can't just live
in that-- you know,
it's like I really feel
safe, and I feel comfortable,
and I'm at home.
But there's just something
over the next horizon
that I feel I want to
step into because this
starts to feel too small.
In the same way the ego is too
small, then all of a sudden, so
is my ethnocentric identity.
It's just too small.
Does that makes sense?
Or maybe I traveled, and I
had another point of view.
Or maybe I immigrated.
Or maybe somebody
immigrated who's
living next to me, and now all
of a sudden that little secure
sense I have about
how the world is,
suddenly I start to feel
like, oh, there's difference.
And guess what the bright
line in development
is between ethnocentrism
and world-centrism?
Guess what it is?
There are a few, but there's
one really significant one.
AUDIENCE: Contact.
DIANE MUSHO
HAMILTON: Difference.
At world-centric,
difference is embraced.
At ethnocentric,
difference is threatening.
Does everybody see that?
So you can almost-- it
would be inaccurate to do,
but you can almost kind of
feel a culture, in terms
of how many perspectives
this can take,
on what its relationship
to diversity is.
Does that make sense?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What did
you mean by the term
"shadow," in terms
of the ethnocentric?
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: So in
order to maintain an identity,
there are things that I
have to keep out of it.
Does that make sense?
So Jung referred to the shadow
as anything that I cannot bring
into my identity as me.
So I used to do lots of
conversations on race.
Race and race
relations, just issues
related to ethnic identity.
And when the identity is
strong, necessarily there
are things that are
left outside of it.
So as Diane, I'm
doing a mediation.
A woman gets upset.
She tells me that
she's upset with me
because I'm flirting
with her husband.
And what is my first response?
I'm not a flirt.
I would never do that, right?
Not me.
It's the not me.
So what happens is the
not me starts to encroach.
The not me start-- and you start
saying, well, wait a minute.
Is that really not me?
Maybe there's more of me
than I thought there was.
Maybe I am a flirt.
You're right.
It's true.
I want to marry your
soon-to-be ex-husband.
No, that's not [INAUDIBLE].
I said, you're the
fool that married him,
and now I have to
mediate your divorce.
Leave me alone.
But it's just
basically anything that
comes in that we can't
hold as I. It's not me.
It's a very famous thing
that we say that when
human beings go to
war with each other,
that one of the first things
we do is dehumanize the enemy.
Because the enemy
has to become not me.
If it's not me, then
I can abuse you.
I can kill you.
I can destroy you.
But as soon as you're like
me, I no longer can do that.
So that boundary
around what's me
and what's not me at
ethnocentric is strong.
And it can be kind of
confusing to suddenly start
to want to move,
or naturally move,
to a world-centric
level of development,
because you don't want
to necessarily push away
your culture.
But you don't
quite-- it's awkward.
Have any of you ever felt that?
Like, there's an awkwardness
in terms of that transition?
And I'll tell you
a little bit more
about that in just a moment
and how to work with that.
So the shadow is really
the pressing in of things
that we don't want to be me.
So another example
would be, it might
be that, traditionally,
being gay is not me, right?
And then all of a
sudden, my brother's gay.
And all of a sudden, my son is.
And all of a sudden, all
the not me is now me.
But the culture I'm in is
still saying it's not me.
That's an interesting way
just to think about it.
All right.
So do you want to grow
now in your perspective,
just get a little bit bigger?
So this round, you're
going to identify
as the world-centric self.
And you're going
to feel, well, what
does it mean to
be world-centric?
In fact, we were down
in the juice bar,
in the Wellness Center, and
I got a nice cup of juice.
And guess what the name of the
label on the plastic cup was?
World-centric.
That's what it said.
So you can identify as
the world-centric self
and see what comes
into awareness.
Just identify and let your
awareness do the work.
What does it mean
to be world-centric?
Two and a half minutes.
Let's explore it.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
So just as an interesting
form of exploration,
as you identified as
the world-centric self,
what came into awareness that
wasn't there when you were
at an ethnocentric--
when you had
another set of perspectives?
What perspectives
suddenly came online?
How about you guys in the back?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Scale.
Often enough, I kind
of go back and forth
between ego and ethno
[INAUDIBLE] communal, but not
world.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON:
Right, right, right.
Yeah.
And yet I think it's
fair to say Google
is a world-centric company,
in terms of its reach.
Is that fair?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON:
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, in
my case, I feel--
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: Very good.
So actually, my capacity to
identify with all of humanity
and to really enjoy
the differences
and to appreciate the
differences is fully online.
One of the dilemmas
of being world-centric
is that when you try to
speak world-centric language
to people who are genuinely
embedded at ethnocentric,
it's a developmental thing.
It's not a moral thing.
It's like telling a
toddler they should
be able to run
better than they are.
Now you have to kind of
try that on a little.
Again, think about atoms.
Think about complexity more than
about dominator hierarchies.
But it is true that
what can happen
is you are filled with this
expansive sense of look
at-- identify with the
ecosystems and lots of species
and what's happening
around the planet.
And I want you to do the same.
And when you don't, I overbear
on you in that kind of way,
where then I become sort of
bigoted in a world-centric way.
It's like I'm bigoted, but
with my own set of values.
Is that resonating with people?
That's one of the
tricky parts of it.
Now, it is possible
when you start
to look at these,
how does somebody
work with perspectives?
How many perspectives are
available in this conversation?
You can sort of start to go,
like, how many perspectives can
we get on the table?
And we'll maybe go to the
limit of what's possible.
And then kind of adapt
to working with that,
instead of pressuring people
to take on perspectives they
literally can't.
They literally don't
come up, so to speak.
And one of the questions
that psychologists
are working with is,
why is it that people
move to a world-centric
level, and why don't they?
And why is it that 70%
of the world's population
seems to be at more of
an ethnocentric level
of development?
In other words, a whole
other set of perspectives
are not really online.
And how can we include
that without devaluing it?
Like, do we have to jettison
the whole developmental lens
in order to treat
everyone equally?
So there's this real kind of
complex developmental challenge
that's in this body of work.
And when I go back to
revisiting the naive mediator,
she just wants everyone to
be the same and be equal.
But she has to be
honest with herself
that the capacity for taking
perspectives is not the same
and that she's kind of up in the
night if she doesn't know that.
Does that answer your question?
If you'll bear with
me for a moment,
I'm going to make an
assumption that the overriding
number of people
at Google are sort
of ethnocentric in
their sensibilities.
Is that fair?
In other words, you can take
an egocentric point of view,
an ethnocentric point of view,
a world-centric point of view.
And then you can
identify as a Googler.
And as a Googler, is that
an ethnocentric identity?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: Yeah.
Well, that's what's
interesting, right?
Because it has the qualities
of, well, this is my company,
and I'm not that company.
Or this is the
lifestyle I prefer.
And then it has all the traits
of more of ethnocentrism.
It doesn't have
the expansiveness
that a genuine world-centric
perspective has.
So in a way, what I
would invite you to do
is just work with this
as a very loose framework
to help you make some
distinctions but at no point
regard this as truth.
Because that starts to
limit, actually, the nuance
and just the open
question that we
have about how are
perspectives at play.
So would you like to
go one more level?
So I'm going to lead
you through this.
I'm not going to have
you talk to each other.
But I'm going to
actually lead it,
and I'm going to touch into a
quality of mind and identity
that maybe I'm going
to put a label on,
and then we'll work with it.
So what I'd like
you do is I'd like
you to identify as the
cosmic-centric self.
We're going to actually
transcend world-centric,
and you're going to
become cosmic-centric.
Now keep in mind,
cosmic-centric includes world.
It includes healthy
ethnocentrism--
healthy-- and
healthy egocentric.
So who am I speaking to?
Who are you?
AUDIENCE: Cosmic-centric.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: I'm
the cosmic-centric self.
So just identify as the
cosmic-centric self.
And can I ask you a question?
As the cosmic-centric
self, how big are you?
Where is that
boundary of identity?
You're limitless.
So you said limitless.
Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: Endless.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON:
"Endless" is a good word.
"Vast" is a good word.
Just, whoa!
But keep in mind, to the ego,
that feels very overwhelming.
Because the ego
wants its boundaries.
All right.
So as the cosmic-centric
self, when were you born?
13-- you guys keep
changing the number.
13.5, 13.7, 13.8.
Could you even say-- and
this is for you-- could
you even say if we
just looked at space,
and we said, I'm
limitless space actually--
I can't quite identify
the boundaries of space.
Can I also, as the
cosmic-centric self,
feel beyond time?
Yeah, can you feel that?
Yeah.
Good.
AUDIENCE: I just want
to say, I feel like,
as the cosmic-centric--
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: OK.
He says, as the
cosmic-centric self,
because I let down
my boundaries,
I feel connected
with everything.
And I notice there's
a sense of happiness.
Nothing really feels
threatening to me.
It's because identity
itself has dissolved.
And when identity itself
dissolves, I'm completely open.
And I'm relaxed in a way
that's really fundamental.
I feel really at home.
What is the practice
that we use to cultivate
this quality of awareness?
Meditation.
So we don't give it that label,
because that label creates
something.
We actually just continually
drop identification.
So as the cosmic-centric self,
what are your preferences?
What do you prefer?
AUDIENCE: Whatever happens.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: I
prefer whatever's happening.
That's awesome.
Thich Nhat Hanh would be
very proud of this group
if he were here right now.
Yeah.
Please.
AUDIENCE: Present moment
awareness and objectivity.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON:
So because time changes,
I no longer am referencing
past and future.
I'm completely in the
here and now, right?
And my awareness is wide open.
There's no sense of limit.
I'm not organizing awareness
around me or around you and not
you, right?
But my awareness
is just wide open,
and I'm very present
in the here and now.
Excellent.
Yeah.
He's saying I have a
preference for expansiveness
over contraction.
I have a preference for
emptiness over density.
But actually, if I
really sit with it,
I see that I am both of those.
There's nothing that
is beyond what I am.
So I'm simply embedded in
the breadth of all things,
in the coming and the going,
in the up and the down-- and in
the peace, but also
in the struggle.
And that's really one of
the points of my book,
is that when you really
do practice and learn
to identify that
you can find peace,
you can find that
quality of happiness
that he's talking about, even
in the midst of challenge
and struggle.
So you become identified, if you
will, with your truest nature.
So that's kind of
really the short course.
And I'd be happy to take
two or three questions
before we finish.
AUDIENCE: Earlier
on, you mentioned
being influenced by a
philosopher and writer.
And I was curious if you
could share the identity
and how that impacted you.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: Yeah.
His name is Ken Wilber.
He's written about 30 books.
They've been translated
into 30 different languages.
They're all still in print.
And you might want to call him
a meta-philosopher, that he
was both, as a
young man, training
to be a doctor and very
interested in science,
but he had a deep
spiritual inclination.
And his whole work
has been about trying
to get those two things
to work together.
So the largest book
he wrote on trying
to create these connections
between the interior world
and the exterior world
is called "Sex, Ecology,
and Spirituality."
It's a very big book, 850.
But what he's trying to do is
name the challenges of our time
and create the
links between, say,
how we work with the
interior of the mind--
awareness, psychology,
phenomenology--
and how we work with
neurochemistry and the body.
And so he's really
trying to create
what we call an integral
inclusion of subject matter.
AUDIENCE: And then are you also
drawing upon spiral dynamics?
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: Yes.
I'm drawing on Clare Graves'
work, which I did through Ken.
AUDIENCE: Great, thank you.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON:
You're very welcome.
Yes, please?
AUDIENCE: As someone who
did not grow up here,
I feel terribly
advantaged in the fact
that I have knowledge of
two different cultures.
And I can pick from
two different places
and select the best
of both the worlds.
Having said that, at times I
feel disadvantaged in the fact
that my ability to relate
with folks from back home
and here is limited.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: It opens,
but it also creates limits.
Yeah.
Other people in the room
who feel that way as well?
That you feel like you've
got this flexibility,
but now you can't relate
to either world fully.
Yeah.
I agree.
AUDIENCE: So this is
more a practical one.
Before, you were
saying about how
we need to become
comfortable with conflict
and become trained in that.
And as a software engineer,
every code review,
every piece of code
that I check in
is reviewed by somebody else.
And so I get that a lot.
There's always this, oh,
no, you've done it wrong.
This is horrible.
This is awful.
[LAUGHTER]
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: Ow.
AUDIENCE: No, this is
a fact of life here.
Everybody's good, and
everybody's picky.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON:
Just do like my son does.
My son has Down
Syndrome, and he'll just
go, "Ow," whenever I
complain or criticize.
AUDIENCE: So just as
a practical matter,
how would you
suggest somebody get
skilled in this who doesn't
have this opportunity?
You can't just say
to your brother,
oh, jump out at me with an
axe every once in a while.
DIANE MUSHO HAMILTON: Yes.
Well, this is one of the things
that I address in the book,
is that basically what
you're talking about
is you're talking about
a third person discourse.
You're talking about an
empiric, engineering issue.
But what's not
being addressed is
what's happening in the
second person, what's
happening in the relational
domain between you
and me when you're giving
me feedback about the work
that I've done.
So great, even if
you're 100% right,
is there a way we can
do that where I just
don't feel kind of
accosted but rather I
feel really supported
and included.
And I think with
that, what I'll do
is I'll give it back to Adam,
because Adam works in People
Dev, and he can actually
answer that question
about how we can bring more
of that quality to your team.
So thank you, everybody.
And here's Adam.
Thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]